hello I'm gav I'm Dan
We're The Slow Mo Guys I'm allergic to
fake cinnamon flavor like you get on a
Tic Tac oh yeah I didn't know that yeah
you shouldn't have told me that
not to worry because I have an EpiPen
specifically my mum's expired EpiPen
important that she no longer needs it
yeah I didn't just like Nick it from her
so when she needs it she doesn't need
I've only really seen them in films and
TV people stabbing each other with
adrenaline and things but I've never
seen one up close I don't really have
any
friends or family with a severe nut
allergy that's lucky is it nuts usually
uh anything any sort of anaphylactic
issue I think it's anaphylactic issues
like that yeah interesting I actually
made my mum allergic to nuts it was my
fault how could you
I didn't do on purpose I was literally
less than one year like I was in her I
was she was pregnant with me oh okay and
the hormones changed her body and she
became allergic to nuts like definitely
allergic
that's mental isn't it yeah didn't know
that was possible we got sidetracked
there a little bit let's go and film an
EpiPen let's do it all right here's a
little ballistic gel syrup have you ever
used one of these before I've not
thankfully
um I know that my mum has used them so
uh but the instructions are pretty
simple take off this outer sleeve
remove the Yellow Cap
and then
I'm not going to do it but you pushing
90 degrees for like 10 seconds and that
injects the the juice actually got no
idea how far in this will go I will say
that I don't know how hard I'm gonna
have to push it in because a thigh is a
lot more solid than this gel so I'm
hoping just Ram it home yeah all right
probe is on let's get a real close-up
nice and tight okay
go for it
oh it looks gruesome I don't know if I
like that
it looks like uh
it looks like all that insect footage of
like a yeah a wasp injecting an animal
like a proboscis going into something
it's very uh it's very Starship Troopers
yeah isn't it
[Music]
oh
gosh you can see the liquid shooting out
you see it like bubbling yeah it's like
it's wounded the gel look where it's
gone in and then you can see the opening
hole luckily the pen was tilted so that
you can see the physical liquid coming
out that was pure luck but there's some
air in there yeah that's good it's
needle up so you can see the channel
That the liquid's coming through I think
the air has been brought in with the
needle through and that's where it's
like that bit in the gel
oh it really expands it doesn't it why
does it lean back at the last minute is
that that's the retraction of the clip
it's the Springs like obviously you have
to bring that part back to shoot the
needle forwards does that mean you can
calculate the speed it was going
definitely I'm just in the edit here
doing some measurements the needle is 15
millimeters long here's the end of the
needle under a microscope if you're
interested in seeing the little channel
that the liquid comes through it's hard
to get across how small this needle is
because I'm I keep showing huge
close-ups of it but you can barely see
the end of it if a scale hears me
bashing the edge of a pound coin into it
based on the needle length of 15
millimeters and the frame rate of 4 000
frames a second I can calculate that the
needle is traveling at 6.7 meters per
second which is about 15 miles an hour
13 14. it like stops and Carries On it
has so much momentum it's like the thing
goes back the needle shoots out which
causes the whole pen to like Lurch
forwards again yeah it doesn't mess
about does it and I love that we can see
the actual liquid flowing in
quite a lot isn't it that's a hell of an
invention if you need something right
this second good I'll save you life yeah
about a little bit of juice in there can
save someone's life what did your mum
say it felt like I have to ask her she
probably won't answer because she's a
boomer
oh it retracts too so when it when it
has a relief of pressure it just sucks
back in for safety reasons I guess so so
you don't like twist it in your leg or
whatever yeah see it's pulling back in
now so it goes
and then comes back yeah it is instant
doesn't mess about does it it's not as
like big and epic compared to like a lot
of stuff we do but that's really
interesting it's kind of like the uh
trunk die isn't it yeah absolutely yeah
it's Monday at eight that's fine
[Music]
no I'll try John blank to be but I told
you she's a boomer
she doesn't answer the phone don't be
silly
not a boom of it
she's actually not a boomer
well whatever these are Jen X Gen X
oh
all right well hang on a second we're
gonna think something's wrong you're
gonna have to ring the landline bit they
don't have a landline actually don't
they no that's very unboomer of them it
is I love the idea of this bigger
expensive international call yeah not
pissing about it I want to know
John
I'm going to fade to black and be like
dance mom never answers
taking up most of the video
you picked Banner while I'm trying to
get a hold of my right
got one more option but they'll see that
I've called them
assume someone's dead
hi mate uh are you uh are you a mums
is she there
uh
uh she yeah she's in the lounge can you
pass it to me please
[Music]
just get her to look at her phone
who's that that's my brother open with
the fact that we're recording her
so she knows
no it's way funny if he doesn't know oh
God if I tell her she's being recorded
she'll go like oh and be all funny all
right we have to tell her after then
yeah of course yeah why'd you only get
one video done today while we waited for
Dan's mum to pick up for half the day oh
yeah is there oh yeah is mum there
oh yeah how's it going
okay fine thank you good good um I just
had a question for you actually
um okay you know your epipens
yes yeah what does it feel like when
they're injected
just a sting doesn't like hurt any more
than a yeah the new ones
to take to sort of take effect pretty
much
of course it hits your adrenaline
because it is adrenaline so it's pretty
much so I can go from being quite
poorly to being feeling like I'm
recovering within 15-20 minutes oh right
wow but it's like the second it starts
to feel better and then 20 minutes later
you're just fine
not just fine but you feel
you feel I feel very you you then have a
very you go into a downer because of
course
um the sort of like an early adrenaline
your body goes hyper and then you have a
sort of come down and say you feel very
very tired
right okay so it's so like is it on like
GTA 3 where you have a bit of adrenaline
and then like everything slows down
around you because you're just all about
it moving so quickly you can just be
like
the trouble is when you take it you you
you are middle and anaphylactic fit or
you feel one's going to be coming on
Yeah well yeah
[Music]
you suffer
um
a morbidity you you think you're going
to die and you have a panic attack
oh my goodness me
all right
wow
and you stick it in you and you just
spill heartbeat going but that could be
the panic attack or it could be sure you
know I see what you're telling me is
you've never tried it without being
actually in an anaphylactic shock
no
no we're actually filming a video right
now is it okay if uh if I have what you
just said on the video
all right cool yeah we're just filming
it in ballistic gel to see what it looks
like when it goes into your body
[Music]
all right well thanks very much for help
cool Cheers Cheers bye-bye love you
oh that was cute I think that's our
first uh interview yeah she did well
yeah she did really well no I told this
video slo-mo of EpiPen plus 10 minute
conversation
people will stay tuned
yeah
yeah all right excellent all right good
info well much like a tranquilizer dart
video that was really interesting yeah I
like the uh probe angle it's really
tight just shows you everything you need
to know in one shot yeah it's that fast
it's quite that much goes out again it's
a cool design it's really cool yeah I I
remember there was a problem with ones
in the Army where people would inject
the people they needed to to do it with
their thumb on the end
yeah they said they would get hit with
the more people your medic takes a shot
of morphine to the thumb yeah
that's not what you want not ideal
hopefully you enjoyed that video make
sure you subscribe if you like slow-mo
and here's another video for you to
watch which probably won't be 60 a phone
call with Dan's mum
maybe I should uh just start a new
channel just for all your phone calls
yeah just chat to my mum